[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour Martin bonjour bienvenue merci
de nous accueillir ces magnifiques chez
vous
avec plaisir Martin Garnier a toujours
honoré les produits et la cuisine des
Premières nations il est à la tête du
restaurant le parlementaire
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il accueille deux jeunes
chefs anoria collier de la nation
wandate et maximizotte de la nation
Wallace talkieway washop pekook en
réactualisant les plats de leurs
ancêtres ils sont devenus des
ambassadeurs de leur culture ici comme à
l'étranger
nous leur avons lancé le défi de créer
des plats défaites inspirez des
traditions des Premières nations les
trois chefs ont laissé libre cours à
leur imagination
un peu d'infusion type du Labrador puis
on va faire une pente avec ça pour faire
nos galettes
on va laisser ça aller quelques minutes
que si on que ça soit parfait pendant ce
temps-là j'ai fait mes petits
canneberges je les ai mis dans un sirop
simple des oignons vous rajoutez mes
petits cornichons d'asley pierre c'est
quoi cette plante là on la connaisse on
la connaît vraiment
bon là
donc c'est déjà un beau condiment de
Noël ça va super bien aller avec l'homme
chevalier voilà pour ça
anouralia collier quant à elle nous
propose une salade inspirée des trois
sœurs habituellement composées de
courges de maïs et de haricots c'est une
salade toute simple en fait j'ai choisi
ces éléments là parce que en hiver chez
les one date dans le fond on utilisait
les produits de la récolte j'aurais pu
prendre le maïs lessiver c'est quoi la
différence entre le maïs qu'on connait
le maïs lui suivait c'est que le maïs
l'estueux en fait c'est un maïs qui a
été séché d'abord ensuite il y a un
trempage qui se fait là avec un produit
de cendres puis ça vient vraiment
changer totalement l'aspect le goût la
texture le complètement différent parce
qu'on se débarrasse aussi de l'enveloppe
du maïs
c'est la graine de tournesol nature sans
épices tout simplement
que on va tout mélanger ça ensemble avec
le riz sauvage on ajoute les bleuets la
cannelle sirop d'érable les fameuses
graines de tournesol et voilà c'est pas
plus compliqué que ça
[Musique]
merci beaucoup quant au plat du jeune
chef maximizotte c'est le cerf rouge les
betteraves et le céleri rave qui sont à
l'honneur parce que j'ai fait c'est que
pendant 24 heures je les ai j'ai faite
mariner à sec ma viande dans mes épices
à gibier je le fais quand même fumer à
froid ou une heure ou deux parce que là
j'ai vraiment
j'ai ensuite effiloché de serre toutes
les parties moins nobles la l'épaule les
parties plus raides de la cuisse alors
l'huile très chaude ici la fume fait
qu'on va y aller tout de suite donc là
on fait juste bien
grave en taille un peu un gros Macédoine
avec du poireau l'ail du vin blanc du
beurre sent bon
petit ketchup de betteraves ici qui est
en fait le betterave cuite avec des
cerises de l'île d'Orléans betterave
cerise c'est une révélation pour moi
cette année voilà c'est le moment où les
plats se transforment une oeuvre d'art
que nous dégustrons dans quelques
minutes
[Musique]
avant le train arrivée à Québec nous
nous sommes arrêtés entre Sorel et
Nicolet à audenac en terre à benakise
chez les nez et compteurs régent Aubonne
sawin et sa femme jacinthe les libertés
pour connaître leur façon de célébrer le
temps des fêtes
il nous raconte leur souvenir et leur
traditions pas toujours facile à
maintenir dans une réserve située si
près des grands centres est-ce qu'on
parle de Noël où on parle de solstice
d'hiver chez vous après des multiples
mariages avec les Européens la question
des solstice ça a été mis de côté la
région catholique s'est introduit très
tôt dans la communauté donc c'était
principalement la fête de Noël qui est
important puisqu'il y avait particuliers
avec la fête de Noël sinon des mecs qui
étaient souvent un échange avec les
Européens mais la fête de Noël c'est on
avait une crèche vivante puis à la
crèche suivante on était en costume
traditionnel soit en et tout et tout ce
qui a fait la popularité de la messe de
Noël pour nous autres au danak le
mariage entre les deux communautés
québécoises et à Benaki s'est fait très
tôt puis il y a continué pendant
longtemps puis on mange quoi dans le
fond c'est un mélange des deux ponts
s'est habitué très vite à ça parce que
étant donné qu'on pouvait pas avoir de
viande ça va
il fallait il fallait se nourrir
merci d'avoir préparé tout ça pour nous
jacinthe d'origine à benakise mais aussi
micmac et possiblement écrit nous a
préparé un avant-goût de leur repas de
Noël on a fait de la soupe puisqu'on
mange à Noël souvent alors c'est des
fèves rouges principalement du Laurent
salé aussi entre larder et on a eu un
petit peu d'orge pour lier le tout
accompagné de une petite banane ou une
bannique à base de sarrasin le dernier
plat que j'ai apporté c'est ce qu'on
appelle la croustade aux pommes mais
nous autres chez nous on appelle ça du
catiminuo on avait du rhumusky
du lièvre la perdrerie
c'était le plus qu'on pouvait avoir de
viande sauvages mais Chevreuse
la même chose il fallait que tu
t'éloigne donc l'agriculture les coupes
à blanc affectent d'Alphonse a coupé
notre nourriture qu'on peut encore
trouver plus au nord on l'a pu
est-ce que le temps des fêtes est
l'occasion de revenir aux traditions
autochtones on voit qu'il y a une grosse
volonté de revenir aux sources mais
l'important dans cette volonté là c'est
de dire puis de comprendre puis
d'accepter puis vraiment embrasser qu'on
est toutes des cent mêler on a tellement
de points communs qu'on devrait tout
travailler ensemble pour
que tout le monde grandisse là-dedans
puis nos enfants nous petits-enfants
puissent être fiers de leurs origines et
pas de dire de laisser la partie de la
victimisation donc le temps de Noël
c'est un temps de réjouissance en temps
pour les parents de se rencontrer les
jeunes puis de faire un échange entre
nous autres
merci beaucoup on a bien acquis c'est si
merci d'être là tout le monde c'est
grâce à vous que si on est tous réunis
aujourd'hui parce que ça a toujours été
votre force de réunir les Premières
nations autour de votre cuisine Martin
je suis arrivé ici à l'Assemblée tout le
monde me dit ah on va voir de la cuisine
des Premières nations à l'Assemblée oui
on dit pas non à ça pourquoi pas j'ai eu
la chance avec un parcours que j'ai eu à
l'hôtel musique de valider plusieurs
connaissances avec différentes nations
du Québec donc pour ceux qu'on est là
vous vous êtes de wendaki vous cuisinez
aussi comme chef à Wendake en ce moment
oui effectivement on a plusieurs volets
au niveau alimentaire à travers toutaine
mais essentiellement pour nourrir les
personnes âgées pour les gens en
situation de vulnérabilité Maxime vous
vous êtes de la Première nation ou à la
stockway est-ce que vous avez cuisiné
traditionnel pour nous aujourd'hui c'est
une question à quel j'adore toujours
répondre
la cuisine en tout cas c'est une cuisine
de subsistance mais donc non ce n'est
pas traditionnel c'est plutôt un
interprétation foraine des ingrédients
autochtones et de des ingrédients
québécois aussi je pense que la
nordicité de notre territoire la
nordicité de notre terroir et en fait un
immense clin d'oeil à la culture
autochtone aussi dans les techniques bon
ben il y a la mise au sel il y a le
fumage il y a utilisé l'animal en entier
donc les os qui ont été pour faire la
sauce au final je pense la cuisine
autochtone qu'on va apporter dans le
contemporain il va surtout être une
cuisine de sens de gros bon sens et non
pas seulement de d'ingrédients clichés à
l'époque peut-être les Premières nations
utilisées beaucoup la forêt boréale pour
se guérir de sa avec certaines plantes
certaines choses puis mais des gens de
chefs qui sont arrivés puis qui ont mis
de l'avant ces plantes là qui sont quand
même comestibles puis on a découvert des
parfums qu'on connaissait mal mais là on
est dans le raffinement je pense on est
rentré aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous célébrez de Noël ou
célébrer des solstice d'hiver célébrer
les deux
diversité puis j'ai jamais célébré le
solstice d'hiver aprèsment dit à moi qui
pelleter son entrée c'est de célébrer ce
soir
que
ni sur une réserve ni dans la culture
autochtone moi j'ai vraiment grandi en
mention de la fondue chinoises
[Rires]
nous on a deux grandes fêtes donc la
fête des récoltes qui est une immense
fête où l'établi sont pleines dans la
troisième de janvier on a un événement
qui est quand même très spécial c'est en
fait notre nouvel an c'est un moment qui
est très très joyeux surtout qu'un grand
nombre de gens aussitôt qu'on fait des
gros événements la saganité labanais que
c'est toujours sur la table les plus
jeunes
parce que c'est la preuve que ça va être
compliqué pour être bon
effectivement j'ai préparé une infusion
de thé du Labrador avec des fraises
fraîches je le sais aussi dans un plat
traditionnel qu'on appelle la pleureuse
pourquoi ça s'appelle à pleureuse quand
on coule que ça passe du réservoir au
contenant ça fait un glissement
glougloutissement puis de l'eau vient le
nom pleurer
pourquoi vous avez choisi ce plat pour
nous recevoir aujourd'hui c'est des
produits qui sont nordiques c'est des
produits qui sont de solstice d'hiver
qui sont de Noël qui sont sucrés salés
est-ce que le plat il est autochtone
peu importe
moi c'est le plaisir de partager de
partager tout ça avec les invités Noël
c'est quand même un temps de partage
c'est important qu'on s'éloigne pas trop
de cette tradition là qui est si bien
ancrée dans nos communautés partout le
partage c'est vraiment une notion qui
est importante je pense dans la culture
tome puis dans ce que va devenir la
cause aussi je pense que tout le monde
devient plus riche à partager son savoir
mais je pense que c'est le mot partage
qu'on va retenir merci infiniment
d'avoir partagé ce repas avec nous